hello there you're watching a game spot
news update with me sub Ford the
PlayStation 4's project Morpheus virtual
reality device won't cost you a thousand
dollars but also won't be arriving in
2014 PlayStation president of worldwide
studios Shuhei Yoshida told GameSpot
today at GDC that Sony engineers are
continuing to iterate on a device and
they won't have a feature complete
version ready anytime soon we asked
Yoshida directly if a 2014 launch date
for project Morpheus had been ruled out
and his response was quote yes that we
can say comfortably because we are still
making changes to the hardware the
PlayStation executive also addressed the
matter of pricing for project Morpheus
saying you won't have to spend a
thousand dollars to get your hands on
the device as is the case with Sony's
hmz head-mounted display line Yoshida
said Sony often prices its gaming
hardware lower than other non-gaming
Sony devices and explained that he
doesn't expect this to change with
project Morpheus as such Yoshida
explained that a thousand dollar price
point doesn't necessarily indicate the
pricing that we're going to have for
project Morpheus as for the competition
oculus rift creator Palmer Luckey is
said earlier this month that he wants
his device to be affordable so as not to
be a rich person's toy but what's your
choice between Morpheus and oculus and
do you think that VR is the future of
gaming do let me know in the comments
below and for a complete comparison
between the two devices head over to our
hub at gamespot.com /g DC